(audience applauds)
- Oh, hi.
It's time for one of mt
favorite segments, "Dear Drew."
All right, I put out a
call to action for people
to send an actual snail mail.
And much to our surprise and delight,
we got a ton of mail.
And I want to get to our letters,
but first I'd love to celebrate
our zip code of the day,
33916 in Fort Myers, Florida.
(audience applauds)
That's right.
It's also home to our local
CBS affiliate, WINK TV.
I don't know if you saw the show earlier,
but animals love it.
(audience laughs)
Fort Myers is home to the only
seashell museum in the world.
And I know, by the way,
I needed to see that,
and it was also the winter vacation spot
of Thomas Edison.
That's right, the dude who
invented the light bulb.
Who knew he was a snowbird?
Which I just learned means
you don't like the cold
so you go warm for winter.
(audience laughs)
Send us some letters, please,
we'd love to open them on the show,
as we are going to do right now.
Letter number one, hello.
This is from Autumn in
Waltonville, Illinois.
Oh, hold on.
"Dear Drew, I wanted to write you,
"and introduce my incredibly
amazing mom, Wendy,
"mom of four,
"and longtime essential worker
of the US Postal Service."
Oh my gosh, this is so apropos!
"I have always loved my mom so much.
"And I thought that you
and I were sister spirits,
"and she's celebrating her
46th birthday this week.
"Would you maybe give
her some kind words?"
Well, Wendy, I love what you do.
And I thank you for delivering the mail
because you deliver love
every day and necessities.
So thank you for everything you do.
Go USPS.
(audience applauds)
I love you.
I am that guy who totally,
like, stops at every person
I'm like, "Yeah!" and
they're like, "Okay, cool."
Okay, this is letter number two.
This is from Nico in
Los Angeles, California.
Oh, my old hometown.
All right.
She writes, "Growing up everyone called me
"a Drew look-alike."
Uh, Nico, you freaking me out.
Like, is this a Photoshop thing?
I mean, this is crazy.
Look at this.
We are the same person. (screams)
Okay.
Thank you so much.
That was Nico.
Thank you.
Okay.
Look, I'm sorting through the mail,
it's not a perfect system.
Okay, this is from Raquel
and she's from Salem, Oregon.
Oh, I love Oregon.
All right, "Dear Drew.
"I love that you're bringing
the written word back."
Thank you.
To you and your animals.
"Thank you for sharing the positivity.
"And I happen to have a
medical bill for blood work,
"and it's been really hard times
"and I've struggled to pay this.
"Thank you for taking the time to read it,
"and thank you for all that you're doing."
All right, Raquel,
I don't want you to
stress over this anymore.
I want you to take care of yourself.
So I'm going to pay your medical bill.
(audience applauds)
If anyone out there has
a bill, needs advice,
'cause I live to give advice,
look, we're all better advisors
to others than ourselves,
and I'm all about self improvement.
So, god, "Dear Drew," I
loved "Dear Abby" so much,
so, you know, any kind of stuff like that,
that hearkens back to a tradition
I've always been a fan of.
If you wanna tell me a joke,
send me a fun family photo, I'm game.
Mail me any thoughts, questions, requests,
heartfelt funny story.
All right, I can't wait to
read more of your letters
on this show and thank you
to my "Dear Drew" pen pals,
Autumn, Nico, and Raquel.
All right, I am going to be
putting these, oh God, stamps.
You have no idea how much I love stamps.
All right, I'm putting stamps on.
I'm gonna mail these in
the mailbox right now.
This is how much I love mail.
I have a mailbox.
All right?
That should kind of show you
where I'm at with this thing.
Here we go.
It's been sent.
We'll be right back.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)